تنياهو رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي المقبل
هذا هو العنوان والباقي مجرد تفاصيل فهو
الرابح الاكبر في الانتخابات التي اعطته
كتله يمنيه كبيره ومتماسكه قد تفضي الى
حكومه اكثر استقرارا وهي المره الاولى
التي سيراس فيها نتنياهو حكومه يمنيه
خالصه لكن نصبتها المتطرفه بسبب نجمها بن
كبير وحزب الصهيونيه الدينيه قد يضع
امامها تحديات داخليه وخارجيه
الجو المريح الذي استفادت منه اسرائيل في
الوضع والحلبه الدوليه اعتقد ان الحكومه
الحديه الجديده ستواجه صعوبات خاصه مع
الادارات الامريكيه ومع الاتحاد الاوروبي
على المدى القصير يمكن
بتوافق مسبقا مع حساب اليمين ان يمرر
قانون تغليب قرارات الكنيست على قرارات
المحكمه العليا والحد من فعاليه جهاز
القضاء
في ما قد يضطر لتوسيع الائتلاف لاحقا لان
فيه 33 نائبا من الاحزاب الدينيه
والاستيطانيه ينصاعون للحخمات للقوانين
الاسرائيليه اكبر تحدي سيكون نتنياه
والضبط الامور الامنيه الداخليه في
اسرائيل تحقيق الوحدات بين شرائح
الاجتماعيه المختلفه داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي ولا سيما بين المواطنين العرب
واليهود خاصه على ذوق الشباب
لمتدينين
والجهات متطرفه الحكومي
اجرائيا تسلم اللجنه المركزيه للانتخابات
النتائج النهائيه الاربعاء المقبل الرئيس
الاسرائيلي وبعد ان يؤدي ان نواب المنتخب
اليمين القانونيه منتصف الشهر في الكنيسه
يكلف الرئيس الاسرائيلي لتلياه بتشكيله
حكومه في غضون 28 يوما قابله للتمديد قد
يشكلها
»
اسرائيل الثانيه هزمت اسرائيل الاولى حيث
هيمنه الاحزاب الدينيه والاستيطانيه وتلك
المستنده اساسا الى اليهود الشرقيين وهزمت
النقب الغربيه واحزاب اليسار والوسط وبين
هذا وذاك فان الحكومه المتطرفه ستكون امام
اختبارات جديه داخليه وخارجيه ثوره
تشكيلها زياد حلبي العربيه القدس الغربيه